Eigentlich ist es ein Kinderspiel.
Doch beim sogenannten Chase Tag sind es
erwachsene Menschen,
die miteinander Fangen spielen, wie zum
Beispiel Enis Maslic aus Deutschland.
Das ist Fangen auf ’nem ganz, ganz anderen
Level mit professionellen Athleten.
Das Tempo ist um einiges schneller
und dementsprechend auch um einiges
spannender.
Chase Tag wird immer beliebter.
In London gab es 2018 die erste
Weltmeisterschaft.
Die Teams treten in mehreren Runden
gegeneinander an.
Jede Runde dauert 20 Sekunden.
Ein Team stellt einen Fänger,
das andere den Gejagten.
Entkommt der Gejagte,
erhält sein Team einen Punkt.
Gewonnen hat das Team, das nach maximal
16 Runden die höchste Punktzahl erreicht.
Für die diesjährige
Europa-Meisterschaft in London
hat sich auch ein sechsköpfiges Team
aus Deutschland qualifiziert.
Sie nennen sich Ashigaru
und sind immer dann zur Stelle,
wenn Freerunner und Parkourläufer für
Show-Events und Filmprojekte gefragt sind.
Chase Tag ist eine Entwicklung aus dem
urbanen Hindernislauf,
weiß Andreas Wöhle
vom deutschen Team.
Um hier mitzumachen,
muss man natürlich schon mit Hindernissen
in Berührung gekommen sein.
Das heißt, man muss Bewegungen,
Techniken draufhaben.
Und wir sind alle Parkourathleten
und deswegen perfekt für dieses Spiel.
Die Brüder Christian und Damien Devaux
haben Chase Tag 2011 entwickelt.
Die Idee kam den Briten,
als sie mit ihren Kindern
im heimischen Garten Fangen spielten.
Wir hatten ein paar Gerüste
und experimentierten
mit verschiedenen Spielfeldentwürfen.
Die haben sich
im Laufe der Zeit weiterentwickelt.
Den ersten Wettkampf gab es im Dezember
2016, und die Videos davon gingen viral.
So fing alles an.
Die Wettbewerbe wurden größer, und die
Athleten immer besser.
Und die Community wächst.
Allein auf ihrem YouTube-Kanal erzielen die
Brüder bis zu 26 Millionen Klicks pro Video
bei mehr als 400.000 Abonnenten.
Mittlerweile veranstalten sie Turniere auf der
ganzen Welt.
Um den Europameister-Titel in London
kämpfen heute acht Teams.
Bevor es ernst wird, macht sich das deutsche
Team mit der Arena vertraut
und erkundet mögliche Stolperfallen.
Es kann immer wieder was passieren,
auch wenn man dann mal schnell
den anderen noch fangen will.
Und dann ist die Hand mal grad nicht da,
wo sie sein soll.
Und dann liegt sie vielleicht mal unter ’nem
Körper, und dann ist da vielleicht ’n Bruch
oder so, aber … Letztes Jahr ging alles gut
und dieses Jahr bestimmt auch.
Dann ist es so weit.
Ashigaru treten im ersten Match
gegen das britische Team Breach an.
Bereits nach kurzer Zeit führen die Briten.
Und trotz eines Sturzes des Gegners
können Ashigaru nicht mehr aufholen.
Sie scheiden bereits in der Vorrunde aus.
Marc Busch vom deutschen Team
sieht es gelassen.
Wahrscheinlich werden wir einfach nur auf
die Straßen gehen und weiterspielen
und trainieren und Spaß haben.
Und wenn es dann in ’nem Jahr passiert,
dass wir wieder eingeladen werden,
dann sind wir halt wieder da.
Genauso machen wie vorher: einfach
weitertrainieren.
Ja, am Ende ist es nur ’n Spiel, so.
Das darf man nicht vergessen.
Den Titel holt im Finale
dieses Mal Frankreich.
Doch was zählt,
ist letztendlich der Spaß am Fangenspielen.